Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number 219
to David P. Here's someone who says it was
wrong for me to go to England last week
because there are there are poor people.
This is this is tough. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: So in a recent email.
I demonstrated. My disappointment slash anger
slash something else. About the fact that you
went to England? Yeah. I don't have an issue
with England. I just have an issue with.
How do you actually relate to the poor
people? Hmm. Do you actually think I or
the people that you supposedly care about can
afford to go to England or France or Spain or
all these places which are out of reach for
many people? So the point of being angry was.
You know. Couldn't you maybe subtract one
of those trips and maybe donate it to a
charity that actually helps the people that you
claim to care about, which I'm sure you care
about, But it's not very well demonstrated by the
fact that you know. Since I've been following you,
you've gone to, I don't know, maybe three or four
or five or six trips that are pretty expensive.
So, listen, anyway.
Speaker 1: Um, I. It's just like, should
I? Who. Who gets to go on trips? Okay. I shouldn't
go on any trips that not everybody can afford.
I should donate all my money to charity. What
about a lawyer who says, Hey, I care about poor
people, so I'm going to do some pro bono work,
But sometimes I'll go to London with my family.
If that lawyer really cared about the poor
people he does pro bono work for. He can't
go to England either. I mean, this is this is
really just kind of a weird path to go down.
And, you know, I know that there are some people
in my audience who are going to write to me and
say, David, you don't have to justify anything
to that guy. You do what you want to do. You
do the show you want to do. If people find that
you are not aligned because you went to England
with thinking everybody should have health care,
then they can choose not to listen. But it's just.
What are we doing, guys? What are we
doing? And what trips would be acceptable,
Right? I mean, should I go to, uh. Should
I go to. Should I go to Hudson, New York,
instead of England as the place I go? Because it's
more accessible? I don't know. I don't know. But
at least this person thinks I did something
very, very wrong. All right. We have a great
bonus show for you today. Mike Pompeo says
he won't run in 2024. Joe Biden has signed
an executive order to improve access to child
care. And the South Dakota governor, Christie,
Kristi Noem. Kristi Noem says that her two year
old grandchild has several guns. What the hell
is going on in South Dakota? And by the way, I may
soon be going to South Dakota. Speaking of trips,
I'll talk about this on the bonus show today.
Don't miss it. Sign up. It joined Bachmann ducks.